salve a tutti ragazzi e ben vedere
questo nuovo video si no se non so
parlare basta chiudiamo il video c'è
stato un tempo in cui ogni ciclo ti
facevo preferiresti che comunque questo
tempo e ancora adesso ma era da un po
che volevo farlo finalmente ne facciamo
uno con i preferiresti fatti da voi
voglio dire che io su instagram qualche
giorno fa ho chiesto nelle storie
ragazzi mette temi due opzioni come se
fosse un preferiresti e io sceglierò le
migliori e ci farò un video sopra
risponderò quale delle due opzioni che
voi mi avete scelto io preferisco
seguitemi su instagram ragazzi tra vj
perché farò altri video così quindi sei
attenti che potrei uscirne con delle
idee del genere comunque partiamo simone
cristauro portiamo preferiresti
rinascere youtube o rinascere il maestro
bini e partiamo già una domanda più
difficile il video è difficile è
difficile perché comunque sia il maestro
youtube sia il maestro domenico bini
sono entrambi e uno è il bate del cibo e
l'altro il batte della musica quindi
bisogna capire secondo me il maestro
bini perché avrei più possibilità di
fare una collabo con martin garics a
furia di mandarli le clip anche martin
si sarebbe mostrato al talento quindi
signor bini o su nice closet questa
pagina incredibile perché mi fa sempre
gli outfit cioè riesce a dire quanto
costano i vestiti co addosso non lo so
manco io come fanno a saperlo loro non
ho idea però vabbè seguiteli presi non
poter vedere guarda leggere rivolte al
mai più per il resto della vita oppure
signore degli anelli mista in sostanza
chiedendo se preferisco harry potter o
il signore degli anelli
preferisco signore degli anelli lo so
che è un colpo al coccige per tutti
quanti però effettivamente il signore
degli anelli è l'opera degli ultimi 100
e passa anni migliore che esista neanche
a riportarci può si può avvicinare al
signore degli anelli prevenirsi
cancellare il tuo canale youtube o
baciare un raggio
chiede gaia sapete che io ci penso
spesso a sta roba cioè non penso stessa
pace di ragni ma a che cosa mi
porterebbe a fare una cosa estrema come
tipo leccare un ragno puoi vivere per
sempre ma per prendere questa feature
deve leccare un ragno e cosa faresti
ovviamente dovresti le calo che vi poi
vivi per sempre quindi è troppo è troppo
una cosa incredibile di fare qualsiasi
cosa per vivere però ogni volta che ci
penso è che mi concentro sono troppo
felice del fatto che nessuno me l'abbia
veramente chiesto perché non so se
riuscirei a fare una cosa del genere
quali faccio vedere due persone che ha
scritto opzione due perché io nella
storia che era questa ho scritto
preferiresti opzione è un'opzione 2 e
l'oro ironicamente hanno scritto proprio
opzione due entrambi ceo della comicità
complimenti ragazzi mingarelli marco
preferiresti vivere 300 anni triste
oppure 80 felici come disse un saggio o
meglio un giorno da leone più mille da
cento e li pisacane preferiresti avere
figli ed una ragazza o essere avere una
ragazza ma che ti tradisce cosa
preferiresti giocare solo ad happy meals
o solo al rocket league
happy wheels è un gioco che secondo me
intrattiene a livello video che 15 per
scherzare di più sopra rocker di un
gioco che gioca di più per i cazzi tuoi
perché comunque ho giocati gli impegni
una partita di calcio con le macchine 15
poi piazzare che in un certo punto per
questo utilizza rocket league per fare i
miei discorsi sulla vita per questo
motivo quindi per me non avere lo credi
che sarebbe una grande perdita quindi il
rocket league
preferiresti essere in the last of us
oil residenti vol
ovviamente ti rispondo le vasto fase
perché residenti vola un po troppo che
lippi nel senso che va anche l'altro
fase però e residenti vol
il mondo è completamente zombie della
stoffa anche però mi sembra d'occhio che
ci siano più avamposti umani nonché il
più delle volte siano sicuri perché ti
ammazzano più mani di zombie però mi
sembra meno krypi ok residenti volo
invece da proprio i dati di via focali
se veramente irrecuperabile quindi dei
lidi al 39 12 codice fiscale tre feriti
vivere in giappone o vivere in america
questa domanda me l'avete fatta con un
sacco di persone ma già ai tempi
rispondo sempre a chi me la fa che
preferisco ovviamente il giappone per il
modo che hanno di per la loro cultura in
generale cioè non è solo perché mi piace
di più a livello di ambiente di vita di
come di come si viva le giornate di come
è strutturata una giornata in giappone
ovviamente dipende anche dal lavoro che
fai giapponesi lavorano tantissimo
ok quindi dipende anche un po da quello
se si parla della avere lo stesso tipo
di lavoro che avresti sia da una parte
che dall'altra
senza ombra di dubbio giappone non ci
sono anche pensare che poco schiaccio
subito tasto preferisci andare ad un
altro tomorrowland o un qualsiasi altro
festival
se potessi scegliere il festival in
questione ti direi un altro festival
perché almeno penso andrea cuccello ma
solo per vederne un altro voglio dire
però il tomorrowland di tutti gli eventi
che ho fatto nella mia vita
rimane il primo in assoluto ovviamente
quindi è una scelta molto difficile
forse sceglierne un altro per averla
costruita di guardare qualcos'altro
punto e con cella però però non è male
neanche tu morrone comunque tre uomini
social per vedersi passare una notte con
giovanni storti o con selena gomez
beh
c'è un senso il buon medico giova
secondo me il mitico giova e comunque
insomma siamo l'ultima ragazzino che
cacchio esce fuori l'ultima massimo
preferirsi lasciare il canale o
regalarlo alla persona che oggi tra
partiti pietro in realtà secondo me il
mio canale gestito da pietro non sarebbe
male come pensate vorrei vedere come
perché non credo sia mai successo nel
mondo che uno youtuber abbia lasciato un
canale ad un altro totalmente cioè non
so se sia mai successa trova non credo
quindi direi da direi proprio di fare
questa cosa per capire che cosa succede
perché non è mai successa salone noi che
mi sveglia dico lascio il mio canale a
step nino è stabilita a fare video sul
mio canale
chissà che cacchio sul censo che si
scompongono gli astri che si crea una
distorsione spazio temporale
scende il governo con questo succede
perché non è di fatto un po strana è una
cosa era cosa molto particolare ci
pensate per la scienza fare la seconda
solo per la scienza come ragazzi questo
era preferiresti con le vostre domande
mi è piaciuto particolarmente sono
sincero fatemi sapere qua sotto nei
commenti quali sono le opzioni per il
prossimo preferiresti che faremo con le
vostre domande e non facciamo mista non
lo facciamo dai commenti di questo video
quindi questo vino ragazzi opzione 1
opzione 2 genitore 1 genitore due quello
che volete
e noi facciamo il prossimo per ferirsi
con le mostrano ma comunque ragazzi si è
visto è piaciuto iscritti al canale come
al solito lasciate un bel mi piace e non
giriamo magiche ma è cosa cosa credi
cosa che faccio st lavoro da 6 anni non
7 in b che culo ai ragazzi
[Musica]